but first biden sabotages america
that's the focus of tonight's angle
during the 2020 campaign anytime biden
was pressed on how he'd deal with the
growing threat from china
he'd respond with the same we are the
world refrain
folks every story in america's
leadership on the world stage
i promise you i will repair our
alliances we need
someone to take office this time around
who on day one
can stand on the world stage command the
respect of world leaders
we should be rallying our friends to
take on china's abusive practices around
the world
now working with our friends are we well
at the same time the media of course
relentlessly portrayed president trump
as a bull in a china shop who was hated
by every world leader
and they sold biden as mr foreign policy
kind of a diplomatic superhero of sorts
able to heal the world
and get nations like germany and france
to work with us on all the big issues
but now about six months into the biden
administration we see that once again
this was another biden bait and switch
come on biden can't even get canada
to open our border to the north and he's
going to take on all of the eu
now time and again we see that biden
sabotages rather than advances
america's interests on issues ranging
from our energy needs to the china
threat
he either projects abject weakness or he
pushes policies that
hurt american families our economy and
national security
now trump saw things as they really were
he understood that world leaders much
like ceos
are generally going to act in their own
interests
unless of course uh they have to cut
deals for their own survival
so america first wasn't just a slogan
for trump
it was the cornerstone of every major
domestic and foreign policy decision
and international affairs protecting our
interests on issues like trade and
border security
required our having leverage against
reluctant allies and aggressive
adversaries
now remember the media and globalists
freak out when trump attended his first
big nato summit oh i do
they were enraged that he refused to
play by the old establishment game
of papering over all the differences
with niceties
well instead he used the occasion to put
our friends on notice
that america wouldn't be the sap anymore
who picked up the check
forever it was time that member nations
started living up to their obligations
nato members must finally contribute
their fair share and meet
their financial obligations this is not
fair to the people and taxpayers of the
united states
of course in the media's eyes an
american president
should never ask our allies to pay up
it's so
gauche and threatening it was an epic
foreign policy fail it's an easy lay-up
missed by the united states
it seems like the phrase leader of the
free world might be obsolete basically
they are not getting along with any of
their european allies
it is really striking the degree of
hostility that donald trump evinces
against nato nato is not like a golf
club there are no dues there are no
green fees
i forgot that jim well and these people
are
still upset about it this was just a few
hours ago i covered the nato and the g7
when president trump was there and i
said well what does a normal summit look
like and they said well first
it doesn't look anything like what
you've experienced they're the in the
the impulses of president trump former
president trump the elbowing of leaders
uh the the calling into question not
what should be done in these
organizations
but whether or not they should even
exist but european leaders were frankly
scared
a lot of them were traumatized president
trump who was just openly hostile
and and was so mean in some ways to our
european allies
so mean to our allies that's yamiche
putting your tax dollars to work by the
way
you see folks at npr in the washington
post
are never as happy as when american
presidents
shrink on the world stage and the global
elites
love it when american leaders apologize
heck president obama's nobel prize was
the equivalent of
i don't know a participation trophy in
global affairs it was embarrassing
both for the nobel committee and
president obama
but i wouldn't be at all surprised if
old joe got one before the terms out at
this rate
it all depends on how much he grovels
and caves on the world stage over the
next four years so we'll have to wait
and see now but seriously
by the sabotage it reaches every part of
the american landscape
in just months we went from energy
independence
to energy depressed trump understood
though that america
was stronger and more powerful when
we're less reliant on other countries
for energy
and when american families are more
prosperous
on the other hand democrats love high
energy prices
and they've always wanted us to pay the
same exorbitant prices at the pump
that the europeans pay why why do they
want this
because they want us to travel less and
use less energy
they kind of prefer us all to be crammed
into cities living in little apartments
like many european families do
the climate change fanatics that biden
stocked his administration with
absolutely detest even the memory of two
dollar a gallon gasoline
especially when it's pumped into i don't
know a ford 150 f-150 blasting country
music
with that really offensive thing called
an american flag bumper sticker
that sends them over the edge now
somehow
old joe thinks americans won't blame him
that their cost of living is going up as
long as he's not rude to the europeans
and as long as he just spouts
meaningless
states cliches back and democracies of
the world are standing together
to tackle the toughest challenges and
the issues that matter
most to our future can't even get the
miking right there
now if america was really back as he
said we wouldn't see china brazenly
signaling it's about to take taiwan
we wouldn't see a flood of humanity
crossing our southern border
we certainly wouldn't be seeing opioid
use skyrocketing we wouldn't be seeing
violent crime spiking
and we wouldn't see a secretary of state
so neutered on foreign policy
that he fumbled the embarrassing
question on how the biden team wasn't
able to stop
germany's mega energy deal with russia
in that nordstrom 2 pipeline
it totally undercuts america's natural
gas industry
the truth is biden has bent over
backwards for germany and the eu
and has gotten virtually nothing for it
zero
other countries even our friends simply
don't share many of our values we have
to understand this
so we can work with them on occasion and
we have some things in common but on big
issues
we have very little in common things
like gun rights
even free speech military spending and
especially on the need to band together
to keep china in check
it's counter productive because it will
push china
to increase its uh regional strategy
it will push china to precisely diminish
its cooperation
on the different agenda and i think this
is detrimental to all of us
heck the french would sell the louvre to
china for the right price
the truth is europe is perfectly content
to play america off china and china off
america
they'll make a lot of demands but give
us almost nothing back
they'll free ride off our vaccine
generosity as they hoard their
own ppe like they did early on in the
pandemic
you know it's bad though for biden when
the press
is starting to write all these
pre-emptive stories to manage
people's expectations on how this whole
trip will go
here's how axios framed it they wrote
it's also not clear to what extent
biden's top geopolitical priority
countering china will be on the agenda
what pine's whole campaign rested on the
notion
that he would persuade allies to support
him
on china and he's going to brussels for
a nato summit and it's not clear whether
countering china is even on the agenda
how is that even possible it's like
kamala not going to the border how is
that possible
but well how is biden's issue not really
possible when
dr jill biden insisted that her husband
had been cramming non-stop for her his
first big trip
i think he's so well prepared i mean
he's you know we've
he's been studying for weeks um you know
working up to today
of course he knows most of the leaders
that uh
that'll be here and um joe
loves foreign policy i think that we're
bringing love from america
i think that this is a global conference
and we're trying to
bring unity across the globe
unity well that jacket jill war
is something my 16 year old might get at
target
but i don't think it's going to impress
the chinese somehow
you know what xi jinping and the ccp do
love though
power and domination
if trump had won the election he would
have had enormous economic leverage
against the eu
and he wouldn't have been afraid to use
it biden however will not
let's never forget that biden and the
democrats essentially agree with the
european elites
who think that american history is
corrupt and it's present
marred by fat evil racists going forward
republicans should make it very clear
that any grand deals biden makes with
europe over the next few years
will be undone immediately when they get
back into power
whether it's the minimum global tax
rates or climate change
vaccine passports global surveillance
all of that will be undone
their ideal world is one where the u.s
is kind of like
gulliver tied down by the lilliputians
where the wto and
other international bureaucracies have
the power and american citizens just
work a lot and take orders
are the europeans going to finally agree
to fulfill their promises on defense
spending of course not
are they going to give us genuine
practical efforts on the china problem
or just more empty words well i think we
already know the answer on that
when the trip is over will americans be
safer will our country be stronger
no and no it's just a political show
it's designed to make you think that
biden is looking out for our interests
but we will have to wait three more
years to elect
someone who will once again put america
first
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else